OF INFORMATION ACT REQUEST
INFLAME CONGRESS.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME TO NEW YORK.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU AND YOUR
VIEWERS.
>> Sean: ANYTHING I'M SAYING
THAT'S WRONG?
ANYTHING I'M WRONG ON?
>> WE DON'T KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT'S RIGHT YET SO IT'S
CRITICAL WE GET THE INFORMATION
OUT BUT IT IS ALARMING AND
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT.
THE CALLS FOR TRANSPARENCY ARE
IMPORTANT.
>> Sean: SOUND LIKE THEY'RE
WITHHOLDING -- MY
INTERPRETATION, THINGS FROM
>> THAT'S HOW I READ THE TEXT WE
HAVE PROVIDED TODAY.
THE TEXT STRUCK REFERENCES 302s.
AS YOU KNOW FROM THE AMOUNT OF
TIME YOU SPENT ON IT, 302s ARE
REPORTS FILED BY FBI AGENTS
AFTER THEY INTERVIEW WITNESSES.
THEY WERE REQUESTED BY THE
CONGRESS AND STRZOK IS TALKING
TO LISA PAGE AND HE SAYS, THERE
ARE VERY INFLAMMATORY THINGS IN
THE 302s WE DIDN'T TURN OVER TO
FOCUS OF THE INVESTIGATION THAT
WHY SIT FOLKS IN THE FBI.
>> Sean: WE HAVE EQUAL BRANCHES
AND OVERSIGHT OF THE BRANCHES.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, THEY FIRST
TALKED OF AN INSURANCE POLICY.
I BELIEVE ANDREW McCABE, STRZOK
AND PAGE.
THEN WE HAVE THEY KNEW NOTHING
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
NOW PETER STRZOK IS LITERALLY
EXONERATING WITH JAMES COMEY,
HILLARY CLINTON IN MAY.
SHE'S NOT INTERVIEWED UNTIL 4th
PROFILE AND COURAGE, LORETTA
LYNCH KNOWS NOTHING'S GOING TO
EXONERATION BEFORE IT HAPPENED.
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WROTE
EXONERATIONS BEFORE YOU DID THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT SHOWS AN UNBELIEVABLY
CONTRASTING APPROACH TO THE
INVESTIGATION OF ONE
CONDUCTED THE INTERVIEW WITH
HILARY AND EXONERATES HER AFTER
>> HE EDITED IT.
>> Sean: THEY HATE TRUMP NOW.
HE WAS APPOINTED BY MUELLER.
THE MUELLER APPOINTMENTS ARE AND
DONORS.
THEN I LOOK AT ANDREW WEISMAN.
HERE'S A GUY WHO GOT IT WRONG,
HE HELD BACK EXCULPATORY
AND OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE SOMEBODY
WHO SHOULD BE HIRED BY ROBERT
MUELLER AND SHOULD THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL BE DISMANDED -- DISBAND.
>> I'M NOT PREPARED TOO CALL
I'M NOT PREPARED TO CALL FOR THE
END TO THE INVESTIGATION.
THERE SHOULD BE TRANSPARENCY.
>> Sean: IS THERE TRUMP/RUSSIA
COLLUSION?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING HARD ON
THIS.
LAST QUESTION, PAUL ROSENSTEIN
WALKED INTO PAUL RYAN'S OFFICE.
I KNOW IT HAPPENED COMING UP ON
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME,
BEGGING RYAN NOT TO RELEASE IT.
AS I LOOK AT THAT BEHAVIOR AND
LOOK AT WHAT -- YOU'VE READ THE
MEMO, CORRECT?
>> I HAVE INDEED.
>> Sean: WILL WE BE SHOCKED?
>> BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE, I DON'T THINK I
SHOULD COMMENT BUT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE AMERICAN
CONCERN ALL OF US.
>> Sean: AND WE SHOULD HAVE ALL
50,000 TEXT MESSAGES SHOULDN'T
ANYTHING ABOUT SOURCES AND
METHODS --
>> Sean: WE DON'T WANT ANYONE IN
JEOPARDY.
>> WE'RE THRILLED TO GET ANY NEW
MESSAGES BECAUSE IF ITS INTO
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT AND
WE REQUESTED THEM TODAY AND
UNREDACTED SO WE CAN MAKE THE
JUDGMENT ON WHAT IS IMPORTANT IN
THE INVESTIGATION AND NOT THE
PEOPLE BEING INVESTIGATE.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN WE NEED
OVERSIGHT MORE THAN EVER.
I AM REALLY CONCERNED A GRAVE
INJUSTICE AND GREAT CORRUPTION
HAS HAPPENED, NOT RANK AND FILE,
AT THE VERY TOP.
>> A LOT OF IS HAPPENING.
WE HAVE A GOOD INSPECTOR GENERAL
WHO I SAID ON YOUR RADIO PROGRAM
YESTERDAY, WE HAVE OTHER WAYS TO
FIND THIS.
GUESS WHAT, HE FOUND THEM.